out of 300 thousand mobilized
our fighters,
men of our defenders of the Fatherland,
150 thousand 150 thousand are in
the operation zone 150 thousand, that
is, half of the troops
in the grouping are in the grouping of
these 150 thousand in the grouping,
only half of these 77 thousand are
directly in combat units, the
rest are in the second  third
frontiers, performing the functions of essentially
territorial defense troops or
undergoing additional training.
Well, in the zone of the operation under these
conditions,
talk about some additional
mobilization measures, they just
make sense, the
need for the state and for the
Ministry of Defense
, there is no such thing today  there
can be only one answer on our side - a
consistent struggle for our
national interests, we will
do so And let no one count on anything else
Yes, we will do it in
different ways, by means, first of
all, of course, We will orient
ourselves peacefully  if nothing else
remains, we will defend ourselves with all
the means of a
long process of results at our disposal Well, of
course, this is a long process
Maybe so, but then you
mentioned that new
territories appeared Well,
this is such a
significant result for Russia after all
a serious question, such a threat is growing
over the fact that Russia will
not use the first
one under any circumstances, but if under no circumstances it means
that the second one will also not be used because the
possibilities of use in the event of
a nuclear strike on our
territory are very limited